[Music]
we noted that one of the ways the beast
um exhibits its blasphemous behavior is
in forgiving sins
now
now in john chapter 20
verses 22 and 23 this is what jesus made
how do we under the question is how do
we understand john chapter 20 verses 22
and 23 in the light that only god can
forgive sins and i'm going to read the
passage
okay
dear lord please once again forgive us
of our sins and please direct us as we
read your word thank you for your holy
spirit in jesus name amen
the word of the lord says and when he
had said this
in fact i guess i should read what jesus
said let's start from verse 21 right
said jesus to them again
peace be unto you as
as my father had sent me even
by you
and when he had said this he breathed on
them and saith unto them receive ye the
holy ghost
whosoever sins ye remit they are
remitted unto them and whose whosoever
sins ye retain they are retained
now
to understand that let's go to matthew
16.
let's go to matthew remember that
incident where jesus said whom do men
say that i the son of man am matthew 16
13. so peter answered verse 6 about the
christ the son of the living god so read
from verse 16 of matthew 16.
all right and simon peter answered and
said thou art the christ the son of the
living god
and jesus answered and said unto him
this is verse 17 yes blessed art thou
simon barjona for flesh and blood have
not revealed it unto thee but my father
which is in heaven a reading and i say
unto you verse 18 that thou art peter
and upon this rock i will build my
church and the gates of hell shall not
prevail against it
verse should i read verse 19 as well
and i will give unto thee the keys of
the kingdom of heaven and whatsoever
shalt bind on earth shall be bound in
heaven
and whatsoever thou shalt loose on earth
shall be loosed in heaven
all right now i will give you the keys
of the kingdom the question is what is
the key of the kingdom we need to
understand that to explain john 20 22 23
and the greater light regarding matthew
16 19 i will give you the keys of it is
with the key of the kingdom of heaven
now jesus came to preach the kingdom of
heaven are you with me that's what he
came to preach
the kingdom of heaven is is upon you the
kingdom of heaven is within you he came
to pray so at a certain level the
kingdom of heaven represents the
principles of the kingdom of god the
principles of the gospel so the keys of
the kingdom have to do with the
teachings of jesus christ but go to
matthew 23 and read verse
of verse 13 matthew 23 13 read that as
we go from scripture to scripture
matthew 23 verse 13
all right father we continue to ask your
guidance
matthew 23 13. woe unto you
scribes and pharisees hypocrites
for ye shut up the kingdom of heaven
against men for ye neither go in your
cells
neither suffer ye them that are entering
to go in
now how do they shut up the kingdom of
heaven against men you see all of this
has to do with uh the question you ask
what you forgive on earth shall we
forgive in heaven he said warns you you
shut up the kingdom how is that done go
to luke 11 read verse 52
luke talks about the same thing he uses
different language one explain the other
look 1152
it reads
for you lawyers for ye have taken away
the key of knowledge ah
okay
the key of knowledge uh-huh keep reading
first you entered not in yourselves and
then that were entering in uh he
hindered
which is the same complaint christ made
in verse
13 of matthew 23 it's the same thing but
luke gives us some information to throw
light on matthew the key is knowledge
now
go back to john 20 22 23 whatsoever
who sins you forgive the forgiven who
sends you remain but in other words
whatever you do on the basis of the word
of god
shall be approved in heaven as it is
done on earth all that is saying is if
you
if you judge and if you act according to
the key of knowledge according to thus
set the law that's simply what it is the
word of god whatever you do will be
approved in heaven because you're using
you're using heaven's standard of right
and wrong the word of god is heaven's
standing of right and wrong and so when
jesus said who sends you remain they're
admitted who sends you forgive you
forgive it it's not that you will
forgive sin but you will realize
that god has done something in a
person's life based on the word of god
in matthew 23 13 you shut up the kingdom
of heaven against men how do you do that
you keep from them the truth you know
this was done for years by the roman
system at one point the bible was on a
list of books that were banned you could
not read the bible knowledge was
withheld john 17 13 this is life eternal
that they might know thee the only true
god and luke explains you take away the
key of knowledge and so when the church
makes decisions based on thus said the
lord what's bound on earth is bound in
heaven but it was first bound in heaven
because it was done on the basis of thus
saith the lord so if you know the bible
says in matthew 18 if your brother
trespassed against you go and tell him
your fault if you receive you then
you've saved your brother if he doesn't
hear you or the church let him be like
some unbeliever or heretic now if you do
that
it's bound in heaven because heaven said
to do that so the decision on earth is
endorsed in heaven because it was made
based on heaven's standard thus set the
lord no human being can forgive sins no
human being can determine a person's
salvation but when the church acts in
accordance with thus if the lord that
action is bound in heaven because it was
taken using heaven's standard which is
the word of god that said the lord
and so when jesus said i'll give you the
keys of the kingdom the key of the
kingdom is the word of faith
amen amen the word all right sorry to
take so long with that but that's a very
serious question you asked
because the catholic church uses that to
say that we can forgive sins you see and
the bible says who can forgive sins but
god so they're not using the keys of the
kingdom to make that claim
amen amen thank you so much for making
that point of the skeet
and
we needed in fact we actually needed you
to actually go through and break it down
and connect verse by verse because we
cannot just use one verse to make a
blessing a lot of
a lot of us do that including adventists
we do that and we try to build a
theology on one verse some churches
build the church on one verse whatever
position you take must be built on here
a little their little line upon line
precept upon precept
amen amen and we know that verse in the
mouth of two or three witnesses all
three yes everywhere will be established
amen amen so thank you elder skeet for
answering that question
[Music]
you